a black police officer in ohio is
speaking to us about what he says was a
racist incident involving his chief that
later made national headlines this
happened in june surveillance video
captured the chief of the sheffield lake
police department putting a paper with
the words ku klux klan on officer keith
poole's raincoat now paul says this was
only the beginning our lead national
correspondent david bagno traveled to
cleveland to sit down with poole and has
the story good morning to you david good
morning to all of you this officer was
just nine months into his job when this
happened to him this was a police
department that was formed 59 years ago
but they only hired their first black
police officer in 2020
and it was officer keith's pool he says
the discrimination he faced at that
department was part of a pattern that
only became public
when this was caught on camera
this surveillance video captured inside
the sheffield lake ohio police
department caught the then police chief
anthony campos senior placing a paper on
the raincoat of the only black police
officer in his department on it the
words ku klux klan
30 seconds later that officer keith
poole walked into the room
people thought i was laughing about it i
wasn't laughing i was distraught like
what do i do with this man he's sitting
right there smiling really he's like
smiling
and
are you
serious
and then he tells everybody everybody
else to come look and see what he did
what's going through your head
it was so demeaning and destructive to
me i
i know what else to do
if that wasn't enough he sat there
and he took a newspaper
and shaped it into a hat of a cone
and sat it there on his head like this
and said you need to wear one of these
on your next call like a clan yes a
clan's hat
four days after the incident the police
union requested a copy of the video
captured on that city camera and that
put the city on notice
mayor dennis bring confronted chief
campo
the chief was standing in his office and
he made a joke
am i going to get fired over this
and i looked at the lawn director and i
said hand him his paper
he said after 30 years this is what i
get i said you have 10 minutes to get
out of your office now the chief was not
fired he reportedly said he was able to
retire
after 32 years of the department and
eight of those years as chief
are you mr campo that doesn't matter we
wanted to ask the former chief why
but we were asked to leave his property
by a man who looked a lot like him
just want to help people
just want to do my job
we always got to
prove ourselves in this job
being black
being a woman
they all got to prove to themselves
and they fair
keith poole has achieved distinction as
an officer serving 30 years in law
enforcement eight of those years as a
school resource officer
to have this man
poke at that
and these kids see that
and they said what was going on with
officer pool
why is he doing that to him
that's only one man
that tried to do damage
but he will not be able to damage me
poole and his attorney ashley k
sleckfold alleged that there was a
pattern of discrimination orchestrated
by the former chief
poole says when he asked the chief for a
new patrol car the chief sent him this
picture of what he could get
the chief also allegedly posted this
picture of poole with the headline
raccoon reaper and poole claims the
chief publicly posted this picture of a
hot sauce bottle on it
the face of the department's only latino
officer
despite all of that officer poole
chooses to still work at that department
why would you want to stay at that
department
the department is not tony campbell
the department is what we make it
he was just part of the department
now that he's gone now it's gonna be a
department and things have gotten better
things have gotten a lot better
well that's because there's a new police
chief and officer pool seems pretty
happy about that mr poole has filed a
complaint with the ohio civil rights
commission next he and his attorney plan
to file a federal civil rights lawsuit
against the city and the former chief
the former chief has not publicly denied
what happened
the mayor says the chief told him
he was just joking
joking and tone deaf i'm so sick of
people trying to hide behind i was only
kidding right you could see the pain the
humiliation on officer poole i so admire
a that he's telling his story to us
and b that he chose to stay because he
said that's not the whole department
that was just that one one officer but
my heart aches looking at what he had to
go through
from the chief who thinks it's funny and
there are people at home that might be
watching this saying well you can't take
a joke it's just a joke
why is it that people of color have to
laugh at things that cause them pain
pain and in this situation that's
exactly what happened it occurred to me
that no matter how old you are you're
never immune to feeling pain he's 57
he's got six adult kids and he said
david it was so embarrassing for me to
have this story be known by others he
has nothing to be embarrassed about
right there's nothing no doubt david
once again great job thank you so much